one point eight million microns work in
Qatar that's 90 percent of the
population
many of them are working on stadiums for
the 2022 FIFA World Cup conditions are
tough workers depend on their employers
for visas for contracts or even to leave
the country and most of them live in
squalid conditions far removed from
local Qataris where no one sees them but
political artists holida body wants to
change that he wants them to be visible
for people living in them it became so
normal to see the workers just you know
coming in to their bus or going out of
their bus and going into their you know
their camps that because we don't see
them we just see them wearing that blue
jumpsuit and and that's it
Friday morning I just you know I see
these guys and you know it's amazing how
did dressed up and how stylish they are
this looks like he's going on a date
really you know but there's no women
around at all so for me that's amazing
you know the fact that you're just
dressing for yourself
dressing because you want to dress up
most of them were so happy that that you
know you were seeing me you're actually
looking at me you know and I think
that's the main point of this project is
is to tell them that we see them
you